back to your question that you had for me, which is this tree service deal. So he's wanting to do
600 bucks a month. How much are you doing with ads? 20 bucks a day? Yeah. So we wouldn't make
anything for the first three months. The thing is, he's a killer business owner. The dude's
crushing it. And so I know he's going to like, that's why he closed that one lead. I mean,
I know he's going to close deals. It's just like, really, like for me, it's kind of, to me, it makes
sense. It's like, yeah, I'm not going to make anything for these three months, but for one,
once I get his site ranked and for two, if I do what I say I'm going to do, he's, he's going to
pay me more. Do you think he would have any, would he, would he wiggle at all? If you said, hey bro,
I'm actually going to be spending like that or more than that in ads. Could you do, I was going
to come back at six 50. Yeah, I would. So here's what I would do is I would go to him and I would
just be straight up with them and I'd say, Hey, look, just so you know, the, the long-term strategy
is be like, I don't want to go too in depth, but long-term strategy, we're going to get you
ranked on page one. Okay. And what's going to happen? What's his name? Mark. You ready for
his last name? Yeah. Ingram, Mark Ingram. Of course. We're about to sign on Mark Ingram.
I love it, dude. You're going up to celebrities. So, okay, Mark. So this is what I was,
this is the exact conversation. I say, Mark, so here's the strategy. We're going to rank you
long-term just so you understand that this works. Once you're ranked, it's not going to cost me near
as much to get these leads in the interim while we're ranking. I'm literally going to be spending
$20 a day. And the way that Google does it, it's $20 times 30.4. It's going to cost me $608
just to run the ads. It's not even including my time. So Mark, what if we did this? What if you
help me out a little bit? What if we do this? And I would, I would go higher. I would say,
what if we do something at like just a three month deal? We do it for 800 bucks a month. You
know exactly how much I'm making. And at the end of the three months, if you can help me get a
Google My Business, which I just need an address and whatever, whatever, whatever, my goal would
be to help get us ranked organically. That's the play. And then as we start to get some organic
leads, then I'll try my very best to keep that price at or around 800, even once we're ranking.
So I would just shoot him straight and be like, dude, at that price, I would love to do it,
but I'm not going to make, I'm actually going to lose money. And that's not even including my time.
However, if you would be down and you, you know, have a good feeling about this partnership,
give me a little bit more. So I have a little bit to cover my time and let's do a three month deal.
We'll do everything we can to get you leads. And also it's going to pick up because the season's
going to change and it's going to get warmer. And you know, just naturally, if nothing else
changes, it's going to pick up. So I would, I would definitely hit him higher. I hit him at like
800 and just hit him and say, dude, I'm going to be, my hard cost of this thing, $608 without
even paying for hosting or my time. So you're going to tell them that. And then just, would you,
would you though, like, would you like, if they're like not, not budget, would you stay, would you go
with a, would you do that other deal though? I might do that other deal. And then what I would
might do is I might bump the ads down to like $15 a day. And then I would just, you know,
do everything that I could to get the Google My Business listing going, get it going. And I mean,
I'd have to be making a little bit of money to make it worth my time. But yeah, if he agrees
to 600, cool. Like then I'll drop the budget to, you know, $15 a day and, and focus on my ads or
whatever and just get, you know, Google My Business. So yeah, I mean, but you can DM me,
we can talk a little bit more. I'll get a little more context, but that's, I would first start at
the 800 mark and just explain. And everyone gets weird. They're like, Oh, I don't want to tell the
business owner that I'm running ads. Dude, who cares? It's like, was this guy running ads when
you called him? Yo, he's spinning, like he did this to see the heart that he's like all he he's
canceling some newspaper ads. So he's spending a lot, like it ain't the money. That's not the
objection. It's, it's, and I understand, cause it's, it's just been so slow. He's worried about
spending 800 a month and only getting three leads. So say this, or you could say this,
you could say, you could do something like this. You could say, let's do a hybrid. Let's do,
let's do a six month deal. We'll do $600 for the next three months. And then the last three months,
assuming that this picks up, let's bump it up to a thousand and you could do some kind of like a
escalated like a contract. Okay. Yeah. No, not, but, or the hybrid is, let's just do 800 across
the board. And you're going to get a few less leads for the next three months,
but you're going to get a lot more than that last three, but I'm not going to charge you more.
Yep. So cool. That makes sense.